what's going on people today we're
continuing to theorize how the plot of
Attack on Titan would have totally
changed if Levi had chosen Evan to
inherit the Colossal Titan in this video
we'll explain how the commander would
respond to Aaron doing the rumbling why
Historia would see memories from the
distant past and of course why there's a
fire breathing Titan in addition we'll
break down why flock would be making
moves behind the scenes and how Willy
Tibu would try to influence the scouts
but before we get into it don't forget
to smash that sub button if you haven't
already and be sure to stick around to
the end if you want to see how all the
different elements come together
okay so part six starts off in Liberia
which is a place that will still be
rebuilding after it was mostly destroyed
during the war seven months ago in the
present day an excited looking falca
would be running towards Gabby and Zafir
because he'd received an important
letter addressed to all Warrior
candidates what makes this letter
special is that it was personally
written to them by Peak who someone they
haven't seen or heard from since her
mcgath and Willie Tiber had to flee the
country ever since that night mali's
government has been under the control of
his route which is why the card time was
never able to send any messages inside
her letter though she'd explain how the
political situation has drastically
changed with many countries including
his room forming a secret alliance
against Aaron if everything goes to plan
this Global Alliance will soon capture
the founding Titan and might also
reclaim the other shifters that were
stolen from Mali this is the news that
got Falco excited because it means his
older brother still has a chance of
inheriting the Beast Titan but in
Gabby's case her priorities would be
totally different in the past year all
of her immediate family has been killed
by the scouse with her cousin Reiner
being eaten by flock her aunt Karina
being blown up by Aaron and her parents
being crushed by the falling debris at
the time of their deaths Gabby was
deployed in the Middle East alongside
the rest of the alien unit and so she
never got the chance to help her family
or say goodbye to anyone this led to her
being essentially cursed by a
never-ending feeling of guilt and
gradually her desire to become a warrior
became overshadowed by her desire to get
revenge in her mind the only thing she
was the Global Alliance to do is give
every island devil the most painful
death imaginable but just as the words
leave her mouth the three of them would
abruptly manifest in the past Dimension
out of nowhere Gabby Zafir and Falco
would hear the voice of Erin Yeager who
introduces himself to the entire alien
race by using the power of the
coordinate during this speech he'd
explained that in response to the island
being recently attacked it's proven to
him that it's impossible to have peace
between Elia and the outside world
therefore to finally put an end to this
cycle of hate he's Unleashed millions of
Colossus Titans with the intention of
wiping out every Last Enemy across the
ocean this declaration of mass murder
would also be heard by the population
back on the island and later that
evening Premier Zachary would call an
emergency meeting in the process Zachary
would hear about how Aaron gained me his
power and reverse the transformation of
all Titans making him virtually
Invincible at this point there's no
personal weapon on the planet that has
any chance of stopping him but from
Floyd's perspective that wouldn't
necessarily be a bad thing the armor
time would argue that even if they could
somehow stop the rumbling it would only
put eldia in a more dangerous position
than they were before in his opinion any
nation that survives this will
inevitably rise up against them in the
future and so the safest option for
their survival is to let Aaron trample
everything however although Evan would
see the cold logic in what flock is
saying he tell the group that letting
billions of people die shouldn't be what
they want in the years before Humanity
knew the outside world existed there was
still violence inequality and
conspiracies happening within the three
Wars themselves bearing that in mind
eradicating all life outside the island
will never be the final answer to their
problems and Irvin would admit that he
wasted his one chance to stop Aaron when
they were in Parts this would cause
Historia to angrily respond claiming
that they can't just give up since she
suspects that anyone even Aaron would
have doubts about murdering the whole
human race if the Scouts can reach him
before he goes too far with this then
she can once again use her royal blood
to bring them into fathers again and
hopefully talk things out immediately
though Evan would ask how they'd reach
Aaron in the first place given that the
rumbling is faster than any vehicle on
the island to outpace the founding Titan
they need something like hizru's flying
boat but currently the only ones that
exist are with the asthma Beto Clan
following a brief pause his story would
reveal something that happened to her in
shiganshina soon after she ate the jaw
Titan in the moment when she was lying
unconscious the queen saw memories from
a previous Titan shifter but at the time
she had no idea who the girl was it was
only after personally meeting Emir the
Historia realized the connection since
the girl in her vision had the exact
same Hollow eyes and so did her two
siblings based on the context the queen
would now be certain that she saw the
memories of Rose Fritz commonly known as
the second child of Emir and apparently
the first ever draw Titan in these
flashbacks historius saw various
Snapchat sorts of roses live but by far
the most Clear Vision was one of her
flying over the battlefield for whatever
reason his story would have the innate
feeling that she could do the same thing
maybe because she's also a member of the
royal family or possibly because
Louise's draw Titan was created using
the Beast Titan spinal fluid whatever
the answer might be the power to fly is
something that she'd feel her Tyson
could be able to do and Zachary would
remark how this makes reaching Aaron a
possibility this comet would cause blog
to have an outburst of the
commander-in-chief as he'd remind
everyone that interfering with Aaron
could mean the death of the alien race
but before a speech goes any further
Evan would cut him off to explain what
they should do next his plan is that
tomorrow morning historian needs to test
if she can really fly and if the theory
is true then they'll come up with a
strategy to locate the founding Titan
the command would reassure flock that no
matter what happens they don't have any
intentions of hurting Aaron but rather
they're just gonna find him and
hopefully reason with him feeling
outnumbered the armored time would
accept this proposal although secretly
he wouldn't be feeling too great about
the whole situation as the media then
comes to an end Zachary would ask about
Willy Tiber and Peak to which Irvin
would confirm that they're being held as
prisoners underground up until now they
both refused to say anything but in the
morning he and Levi are going to try
again to get some answers in the
meantime though the Commander's main
priority is dealing with all the alien
refugees who were used as Weapons by the
Global Alliance prior to being turned
back into humans by Aaron our laser as
the wall Titans continue to March
through the night Mikasa would lay in
bed questioning how all of this could
happen from her point of view the real
Aaron would never trample innocent women
and children and so she tried to
rationalize his actions by telling
herself that yamir must be controlling
him as Mikasa moves from one explanation
to the next Connie and Sasha would be
making their way to ragako Village
thanks to Aaron undoing the
transformation of every Titan the two of
them would have hoped that Mrs Springer
also reverted into human form for the
past five years she's been stuck in
ragako as an upside down Titan so if
Aaron really has ended her suffering
then that act of kindness would be
enough to earn Connie's undying loyalty
meanwhile over in Chicago
would have fallen asleep to the sound of
the rumbling and in his dreams he
manifests in front of a tree at the
bottom of this tree would be an old
grave covered in cracks but as he leans
closer he noticed the name inscribed on
it is none other than Aaron Jaeger in
his confusion he keeps staring at the
headstone to make sure he's reading it
correctly but you soon get distracted by
the objects flying overhead as flock
turns around he'd see a futuristic city
in Ruins with strangely shaped aircrafts
relentlessly dropping bombs all over the
place these bombs would cause the
buildings to fall apart and in the blink
of an eye he'd be transported to the
streets of an empty sugar seeing the
town in this state would remind him of
how it looked five years ago when he and
Irvin were nearly killed here by the
Beast Titan flock would think to himself
the LDS should never be allowed to end
up in ruin like this again and after
suddenly waking up he'd feel certain
about what he has to do to prevent his
home from falling into ruin at the hands
of the Invaders it's his responsibility
to make sure Aaron survives no matter
what the next morning down in the prison
cells P could wake up to the site of
Levi and the commander hanging around
outside next star Willie would already
be awake but he'd still be too
traumatized to speak after witnessing
the rumbling first hand without wasting
any time Levi would then begin
interrogating the card Titan because
he'd want to know how she found out
Zeke's location remember only the
highest ranking people like Zachary and
Irvin were aware of its location in fact
even the captain himself didn't know
where it was until yesterday for that
reason he'd want to know how a foreigner
from Mali got a hold of that information
but during the questioning Peak was
stayed totally silent this is when
everyone would jump in as he tried to
get a reaction by telling both Prisoners
the rumbling is their fault for
attacking the island the car Titan will
respond by glaring directly at him and
after getting her attention the
commander would slightly change his tone
in a moment of honesty he'd revealed
that he personally didn't want this to
happen and although eldia has no method
of stopping Aaron by force there's still
a chance that they might be able to save
some lives looking peak in the eyes he'd
ask her if she still has people in Mali
that she wants to save causing her to
think back to the young Warrior
candidates the cart Titan would feel
like a failure for giving them false
hope without better since by now Gabby
Falco and the rest must have worked out
the Global Alliance Was Defeated at the
same time Willy would think about his
wife and his many many children and the
mental image of them getting trampled by
the rumbling would make him want to
throw up following this everyone would
claim that despite being enemies he's
willing to save their families if they
tell him what he needs to know Peak
would reply by asking why they should
trust him but before she could finish a
desperate will he confesses that it was
kyomi who told them Zeke's location for
several years hisaru have been desperate
to improve their Global reputation but
after invading Mali things hadn't been
going as well as they expected this is
largely because Willy had been using his
political and media connections to turn
the world against her with the asmabito
getting hit with economic sanctions
gradually kyomi became so desperate to
turn things around that When Willy
contacted her she was more than willing
to listen to his proposal the deal they
agreed was that in exchange for her
passing on Vital Information history
would gain two things number one they'd
no longer be viewed as friends of the
alien Empire which meant no more
economic sanctions and number two in the
future they they gain exclusive access
to eldia's Natural Resources Evan would
reply pointing out that the asthma beta
already have access to the iceberg Stone
but Willy would explain that history
wanted all of the reserves if the Global
Alliance had been successful in their
plan to steal the founder it was
Ambassador kyomi who then planned to
take full control over the island after
hearing that Revelation everyone would
feel an incredible sense of
disappointment since his biggest Ally
turned out to be a traitor just like
Aaron predicted this would cause the
commander to rethink whether they should
even try to stop the rumbling because
without hisaru's technology on their
side the island would become incredibly
vulnerable when modern weapons surpassed
the power of the Titans noticing the
look on Evan's face Willy would tell him
there's still One path they can take
where everyone survives but it would
involve making one sacrifice to explain
this plan he'd start by confessing that
he's always viewed being held in as a
curse and if it was up to him he'd never
been born in the first place having said
that hearing Aaron's declaration made
him realize that he is afraid of dying
and more importantly he doesn't want any
of his kids to die either saving their
lie is what matters to him more than
anything else and to accomplish that
he's willing to help Irvin in whatever
way he can the commander would question
what exactly will he is suggesting here
and this is when he'd reveal something
pretty interesting a hundred years ago
the Tibet family took credit for
defeating Carl Fritz who was one of the
previous founding Titans and from that
moment they were all treated like
royalty despite being albians thanks to
the actions of his ancestors Willie
enjoyed a life where no one ever judged
him for being a subject of Emir proving
that humans and Aliens can trust each
other under the right circumstances just
like how the tivers are widely known as
Heroes who save the planet the same
could happen for urban and the scouts if
they somehow start the rumbling to
guarantee that no one lays a finger on
the island Willy could use his political
influence to tell the story of how they
saved Humanity from Extinction his
reputation as a type it would make
people more willing to accept the scouts
as their saviors but of course the
sacrifices that they'd have to kill
Aaron without Aaron's death the story
would feel incomplete as the world would
still view Aldi as a threat to all of
their lives for that reason the founding
Titan has to die and most importantly
the Scouts have to be the ones to do it
a proposal like that would instantly
catch Levine Irvin by surprise but
before they can properly respond a
horrified Mikasa burst into the room
judging from the look on her face the
commander would wrongly assume that she
just heard what Willy said but in
reality she didn't hear any of that she
was reacting to something else while
Evan and Levi were down here in the
prison Mikasa and flock spent the
morning with Historia testing whether
the queen could really use her Titan to
fly during these tests though the queen
would accidentally do something that no
one else was expecting and Mikasa would
beg the commander to come and take a
look for himself the following day the
rumbling would start to have an impact
in all corners of the Earth with the
Titan setting foot on multiple
continents over in the Middle East
people would run for their lives as
their whole civilization is crushed into
the ground while in Asia kyomi's worst
fear would become a reality two days ago
she suspected something wasn't right
when his rule lost contact with the
Global Alliance and that uneasy feeling
was made worse when she heard rumors
about eldians receiving a message from
Aaron in response the asimovies made
extensive preparations to deal with any
Potential Threat mobilizing their flying
boats anti-tying cannons and warships
sadly for them this wouldn't be enough
as the war Titans would easily brush off
every single attempt to slow them down
continuing to March full speed into his
room as kyomi then watches her country
get trampled to dust she'd wonder what
would have happened if she'd made a
different decision when Willy first
approached her with his proposal she
agreed to help the Global Alliance since
it seemed like it was the only way hizru
would be accepted back onto the world
stage however if she answered
differently and decided to stick with
Evan and the scouts then things probably
wouldn't have come to this in her final
few seconds before the rumbling crushes
her to death kyomi would think briefly
about Mikasa because as the only Asian
living in Elia she'll be the law
surviving member of the asmabito clan
now switching back to Liberia the ground
would be violently shaking as the Titans
make their way further into the city a
couple days earlier when the eldians
heard Aaron's message they tried to
convince the guards to let them escape
triggering a violent military response
that led to several casual days as a
result most people inside the internment
Zone became too afraid to speak up and
they chose to spend their final days
with their families rather than fighting
against the guards in Gabby's case she'd
be spending time with Falco and the
Grise family and right now they'd all be
terrified as the rumbling marches
towards them at the front of this March
would be Aaron who's personally leading
his army of Titans into Liberia and the
site of the attack Titan would cause a
stampede of people to run away Gabby
herself would stay frozen in fear
knowing there's no point trying to
escape but Justice things seemed their
most hopeless an unidentified creature
quickly speeds through the sky seeing
this from below the young Warrior
candidate would instantly recognize it
as a Titan even though she's never seen
anything like it Colt would speculate
that somehow this shifter might be Peak
because to him she's the only person
left who'd be willing to charge
headfirst into the rumbling the reality
however is that this flying Titan is
Historia and riding on her back would be
Irvin flock Mikasa and Captain Levi
their mission right now is to peacefully
convince Aaron to stop the rambling and
that means doing what they can to
distract him while Historia tries
estimate contact if successful this
would give them one final chance to talk
things out in the past Dimension but in
the back of Evan and Levi's heads they
couldn't help but remember the warning
they got from Willy Tiber as the jaw
Titan then flies over the rumbling her
mouth would start to Glow in a way that
shocks everyone watching from inside the
internment Zone following a few seconds
of build up Historia then releases a
blast of superheated steam vaporizing
the names of about a dozen Titans
marching towards Liberia those Titans
then fall to the ground causing a chain
reaction where other times start to fall
over them and it's at this point Gabby
would feel a sense of Hope For The First
Time by the way in case you're wondering
how this ability Works similar to the
Colossal Historia is able to burn muscle
mass to generate steam but instead of
emitting that steam she can store it
internally when the heat then builds up
to an excessive temperature her Titan
can release it in one go melting pretty
much anything that happens to be in the
way the downside to this power is that
like I said she needs to burn muscle
mass to do this meaning there needs to
be a long regeneration period before she
can do it again anyway with a whole
section of wartime is being wiped out
Aaron would be surprised and mildly
impressed by the attempt to stop him
based on what happened in pars he knew
that Evan and Historia weren't happy
about his choice but he never imagined
they'd go out of their way to stand
against him what makes it worse is that
Meeks is also part of the group and for
a second her presence would make him
question if he's really doing the right
thing his primary motivation for doing
the rumbling was to protect the few
people he has left but if those same
people truly don't want him to do this
then it's at least something to think
about as Aaron stays deep in thought
Aaron would then dramatically leap from
Historia to activate his colossal
transformation the Commander's job in
this moment is to essentially be a
distraction by blocking the attack
Titan's path giving the draw enough time
to swoop in remember all his story has
to do is make their faintest contact for
her plan to succeed and it's why
everyone would scream at the top of his
lungs to try and get Aaron's attention
despite the Commander's best efforts
though Aaron's eyes would stay firmly
fixed on Historia as he tries to assess
what's going on he knows that if the
scouts were here to kill him then
there's no way mikasu would be involved
but at the same same time if they're
here to stop the rumbling then there's
no way they can do that without killing
him while Aaron racks his brain trying
to figure out what they're up to his
story will suddenly pick up the speed
and within a few seconds she'd be inches
away from making contact a blinding
flash of light would then engulfed the
jaw Titan but as the people of Liberia
observe the situation pretty quickly
Evan would realize something's wrong the
scale of this lighting would be a
thousand times larger than expected
since the last time his story attached
Aaron she said there was only a tiny
spark this would cause Evan to ask
himself what could possibly be different
I had to answer that question we need to
flash back to their meeting with Zachary
during that conversation flock got the
strange impression that the scouts care
more about saving their enemies than
they do about saving their own people
his paranoia got worse after having a
dream of eldia's future destruction and
so later that same night he made
preparations to find out the truth
knowing that Evan would interrogate the
prisoners from Mali flock paid one of
the MPS to listen in and report
everything back to him the following
night this meant that when Willie Tiber
gave the commander a speech about
needing to kill Aaron one of the Gods on
duty was secretly spying for the Armored
Titan at no point did the guard here
Irvin or Levi reject Willie's proposal
and when you remember that Levi is
immune to the Founder's mind control
killing Aaron is actually within the
realm of possibility in theory all it
takes is for someone of Ackerman blood
to be brought face to face with the
attack Titan and once they're physically
there nothing can stop them from slicing
the nape these are the thoughts the
flock could be telling himself after
finding out what will he said and at
this moment he knew that somehow he had
to intervene that's why he pretended to
be a good soldier as the scouts moved
forward in their mission to stop Aaron
and that's why in the second before
Historia made contact he found the
courage to detonate his Titan it was
flock's transformation into the armor
that triggered this blinding flash of
light preventing Historia from touching
Aaron while also blasting the acumens at
close range his intention here was to
eliminate the last remaining threats to
the rumbling ensuring that future
generations of aldians won't suffer the
same fate he saw in his dream with the
ackermans gone there's no one left on
Earth who can stand against the founder
and as Levi Mikasa and Historia plummet
towards the the ground Aaron in the
commander would only be able to watch on
in disbelief with that said that's the
end of part 6 of what if Evan got the
Colossal Titan and if you want the
series to continue then don't forget to
hit that like button and obviously
subscribe so you don't miss future
content like this also I'm interested to
know what your favorite part of this
particular video was so if there's a
moment that stands out to you then let
me know in the comments down below and
until the next one peace out